back tonight Hell's Kitchen on Fox in we
tagged along with chef Gordon Ramsay as
he cooked up a big surprise for some
deserving kids IAT is Gordon now I'm at
the Martin de Porres High School they've
got no idea I'm here and they are in for
the shock of their lives
ICU lecturers for today we're used to
seeing his fiery side but when he
dropped in to teach a cooking class at
this New York High School for at-risk
youth we got to see a kinder and gentler
Gordon why is it so quiet here what's
happened now come on
these young students I was one of them
I've never forgotten that when I was
your age of 16 my parents couldn't
afford to buy my my whites my apron my
hat
I got plucked out of a sort of
dysfunctional school when I was their
age
and the odds of me making it was very
slim we're gonna make the most amazing
cheesecake so if I can enlighten these
guys and just let them know how
important is to do well with food you're
gonna be unstoppable but don't expect
him to be a softy all the time the chef
who's got a new cookbook out and a new
online master class will be back to his
hot-headed ways when Hell's Kitchen
returns tonight
this season it's rookies versus veterans
are you ready to do battle
I like the underdogs why as an underdog
myself and even though I'm at the top of
my industry at the moment I still
consider myself inside an underdog
[Music]
[Applause]
you